[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY: Hi, I'm Jimmy.
I won't waste too much of
your time by being up here.
I'm just here to introduce
Brian, host of Techmeme's "Ride
Home" podcast.
Recently wrote a book called
"How The Internet Happened,
From Netscape to the iPhone."
Brian's got a history of
working in the tech industry
and startups.
He'll talk more about that.
But essentially, amassed
a whole lot of knowledge
about the history
of the internet
and wrote this book in his own
words, because no one else had.
And will share a lot
of interesting things
that he learned along
the way with us.
I'll also just note that
there are books for sale,
as usual with these things,
at the subsidized price
for Googlers.
So feel free to pick
one up on your way out.
And with that, Brian McCullough.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH:
Thank you, Jimmy.
I'm going to stand up here
so I can quote from the book
once or twice.
Thank you all for coming,
and thanks, Google,
for having me come.
As Jimmy said, I'm actually
not a historian or a writer.
This is my first book.
I'm a three time web founder.
Actually, funny
enough, I've said this
on many of my podcasts,
my first company
I founded in '99
I've said many times
was 100% built on AdWords back
in the day when it was still
useful and not filled with spam.
But in my memory, the day that
y'all opened it up for the self
serve thing is the day that
I got on AdWords and, god,
I can remember paying $0.08 a
click for the keyword resume
and things like that.
It was nutty times.
So the reason that
I did this book,
my second startup was
2002, my third 2005.
It just sort of
bothered me that there's
excellent books, of
course, about the history
of the ARPANET and
things like that,
but the actual internet
going mainstream
and entering normal people's
lives, no one had done.
And I just got tired of
no one writing that book.
So like any other startup
I've done, I was like, well,
someone's going to do that.
Why not me?
It's the dumb startup mentality.
So the reason I give
you that background
is it's also sort of my career.
It's what I lived.
So I thought it
would be easy to do.
And so what I want
to do in this talk
is tell you some
of the fun things
that I learned in
doing the research.
It was five years of
writing, essentially.
And I did actual
go to the library
and find defunct magazines
and things like real research.
Also, by the way, and
also, because I'm a web guy
and I'm used to
instant gratification,
over the course
of the writing, I
launched the "Internet
History Podcast,"
which there's almost
200 episodes now,
which was me doing interviews
for primary sources.
I just had just this
week Ken Norton of GV.
Last month we had Matt Cutts.
I've had Charlie Ayres on.
So there's plenty of Googlers
that have been on the show
if you want to check that out.
But the reason I give you that
background is, like I said,
I just want to go through
and sort of chronologically
and tell you some of the things
that even though I thought
I knew all this stuff
because I lived it
that were sort of
surprising to me.
What has been
surprising to me as I
do media hits for this book
is, they almost can't help
themselves, the first question,
especially on radio, is always,
I thought Al Gore
invented the internet.
So I have come up,
fortunately it's in the book,
I have a pat answer for that.
In 1992, or actually
1991, there was a bill
passed called the High
Performance Computing
Act, which was colloquially
known as the Gore bill.
And it funded a bunch of
supercomputer facilities
around the country, one of
which was the NCSA, which
is where the Mosaic web
browser came out of,
which was where Marc Andreessen
was going to school, which
is where all the Mosaic
kids that would later found
Netscape all went to school.
And so, as I say in the
book, essentially when
they were being paid
$6 an hour to code
in the basement of the NCSA
at the University of Illinois,
they were being paid
by Al Gore's Gore bill.
So it's not exactly apples
to apples, but in a way,
you could say that that played
a major role in the internet
going mainstream.
Because as I make the
argument in the book,
Netscape was the first true
dot-com, or web company,
as we would think of it today.
So let's begin there,
actually, because there's
a million reasons
why I think Netscape
was the big bang for the modern
era, as I call it in the book.
Not the least of
which is the culture.
When I started
researching, the reason
I threw it up as a
podcast is I worked my way
through the entire
Mosaic engineering
team that went out to
California to found Netscape,
sans Marc Andreessen, who
even though we talk on Twitter
refuses to come on the show.
But the thing that
I found fascinating
was this idea of startup
culture and how a lot of it
was borne by the media
attention that Netscape
got when it IPO-ed 1995, which
we'll get to in a second.
To a person, all
of the Mosaic slash
Netscape engineers,
almost unbidden by me,
wanted to make the point that
they're like this sort of work
hard, sleep under your desk,
party hard sort of startup
culture, they're like
we didn't do that.
The media did that to us.
They really were the
original Mosaic six
that went out to found Netscape
with Marc Andreessen and Jim
Clark.
These were literal corn-fed
Midwesterners fresh out
of college, 22, 23, 24.
And so as Aleks Totic told me in
the book, and I'm quoting him,
"We were working
around the clock
because that's what
you use to do before.
Four years later, five years
later, the entire valley
would be living
the same lifestyle.
But those people
actually have lives.
We really didn't have any
lives outside of the office.
So of course, we were going to
be at the office all the time.
I mean, I had no furniture.
Why should I ever go home?"
And Lou Montulli, who
some of you might know,
said, "The press
just take what they
think is interesting,
juicy, and fascinating out
of their limited time
and they publicize that.
Especially post
Netscape in '98, '99,
every startup was
trying to do the things
that they read about
in the magazines
that they read about us.
I would catch four or five
hours of sleep at the office,
wake up, do another 20, go
home, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But I wouldn't recommend doing
that for your average startup.
Unfortunately, a lot
of startup people
think that that's the way it
should be done because of all
the publicity that we had."
Another point that
I make in the book
is that Netscape was the big
bang because the rock star
entrepreneur universe
that we live in,
if you were around in the
'80s and the early '90s,
that wasn't a thing.
Kids grew up to want to be
rock stars and sports heroes,
and maybe if you
were super ambitious,
you went to Wall Street.
But the idea that you
would start a company,
that was not in the zeitgeist.
And the fact that Netscape had
this famous IPO in 1995 that
made, I actually
remember clearly,
it made the nightly news
and things like that.
The idea that there
was a new company,
that there was a company
that had been around
for 18 months that had no
profits that was worth $2
billion on the day of its IPO.
I've interviewed
Wall Street people.
It blew their minds
at the time too.
So I devote the
entire first chapter
to telling the Netscape
story because of some
of the things, the groundwork
that it laid for this era
that we've been living in ever
since, essentially, the last 25
years.
Back to their sort of work
hard, play hard culture.
The other thing
that Netscape did,
and this is obvious when
you state it, but think
of how conceptually
what a leap this was.
These were the first guys to
have a product where you would
distribute it on the internet.
Literally before them, you would
still put software in boxes,
shrink wrap it, and put
it on a shelf, right?
So this concept of doing
versions, that you get feedback
from your users, and you put
out a dot whatever release,
two weeks later another release.
So one of the reasons,
obviously, that we now
live in this 24/7
product cycle is
because they were
the first people
to jump on that sort of
a distribution mechanism
as a way to do
software products.
But also because, like everyone
else at the time, this is 1995,
they were outracing Bill Gates.
And so another thing that
I was surprised when I did
the research, because again,
most of my career was spent
in the '00s.
And god bless them,
no offense Microsoft,
but they've been in a sort
of lost decade in the 2000s.
It was a surprising reminder
to me how much everything
in the '90s, what everyone was
doing was in relation to what
Microsoft might do
or try to stand--
Googlers have told me on the
"Internet History Podcast" when
AdWords finally
took off and were
making butt loads of
money, it was a thing,
don't tell anybody.
Don't let the word
get out until we're
far enough along that Gates
can't catch us, essentially.
So that was surprising to me how
much in the first few chapters
Microsoft constantly comes up.
I go into in depth how Bill
Gates got internet religion.
I talked to a bunch
of Microsoft people.
It was really very much
a generational thing.
It was the guys at Microsoft in
their late 20's and early 30's
who had used the
internet in college.
Not that Bill Gates hadn't.
In fact, he and Paul
Allen, when they
were writing their
first software products,
were using because they were on
opposite sides of the country,
so they were FTP-ing
back together.
It was more generational
in the sense
that a guy like
Gates, born in '55,
baby boomer, as much
as he loved computers,
he really didn't
believe that computers
were mainstream enough.
If you guys remember things
like web TV and stuff
like that they did.
And if you remember a
term like the information
superhighway,
which people think,
well, that was the internet.
No, they had a vision that
they were going to deliver.
Once broadband became
ubiquitous, which Gates figured
would happen after the year
2000, which he was 100% right,
then they would deliver
this curated Microsoft,
safe for the masses,
interconnected computing
product via the TV, because
the TV was the one thing.
It wasn't until 1998
or '99, don't quote me
on that, that
computers penetrated
50% of US households.
So again, if you're
Bill Gates in '94, '95,
you're not worried about the
internet, because it's not
going to ever be mainstream.
It's not good enough,
because it's not broadband.
You can't do movies
and things like that.
The thing that he missed
was that it was good enough.
And people were excited
about it and were
willing to put up with it
takes two minutes to download
a JPEG or something like that.
So I want to give credit to
the people like Brad Silverberg
and Slivka.
I can't remember his first name.
The younger guys that had to do
sort of the generational push
to the older people
at Microsoft to say,
this is really happening and
we've got to jump on board.
Another reason that
I did this book is I
still dabble in a little bit
of angel investing and things
like that.
And when I meet with young
people, young founders, 26, 27,
and they say, oh, you
remember the dot-com.
You were there for
the dot-com era.
What was that like?
When I've done episodes
on AOL, when I get emails
and tweets saying, thank you.
I've never really understood
what AOL's business model even
was.
Which I get if the internet's
just always been in the ether.
AOL was always pejoratively
called the training wheels
for the internet.
But I argue in the book that
was incredibly valuable.
Somebody needed to be
the training wheels.
This book is very much about
how the internet went mainstream
to people like our parents.
And many, many Americans,
at some point something
like 70% of all internet
traffic in the US
was going through AOL's pipes.
So many people got their first
taste of not only the web
and the internet but computing
and living online, learning
what it means to have an online
persona and a screen name.
And that can mean going
into the chat rooms
and talking sexy chat
and stuff like that.
But also finding
those little areas
of the internet where
your interests are,
where your people are.
So I spent a long time talking
about AOL, giving them credit.
I interviewed Jan Brandt, who
was the marketing guru behind--
if you were alive then,
there was a time when you
couldn't open a magazine,
you couldn't-- they put them
on sports stadiums.
They put him in Omaha Steaks.
You couldn't go anywhere
without getting a free AOL disk.
Originally disks and
eventually CD-ROMs.
Her brilliant insight was,
again, this is '95, '96,
computers are only in
30%, 40% of households.
She had the choice
of this is a product
that no one understands,
and either I
have to spend all
of my marketing time
educating people on what
it means to go online
and what you can do and why
you would even want to do it.
She told me that
they would have--
what do you call it?
They're behind the mirror
and they're having consumers.
Right, focus groups
and things like that.
And people would sit in front
of a computer, take the mouse,
and put it on the
floor because they
think it's like a sewing machine
pedal and things like that.
So her insight is forget that.
I just need them to try it.
That's it.
So if I can just get these
disks so that they're
collecting in corners like
tumbleweeds, if I can just
get somebody to put this
in their computer one time,
I don't have to educate them.
They'll figure out
what is useful to them
about this product.
So it's gone down in history as
one of the greatest marketing
campaigns of all time.
When she started
that campaign, I
think AOL had less than
400,000 subscribers.
Obviously, at its height
it had 30 million.
So all credit to Jan Brandt.
I also give a lot
of credit to Yahoo!
for being what I call the
first great web company,
the first great company
that couldn't have
existed without the internet.
Because you can argue that
Netscape with a web browser,
that's still a software product.
But Yahoo! even though it wasn't
technically a search engine,
it was a human
curated directory,
but they essentially did
search for most people
at the very beginning.
I look at Amazon.
The thing that I found
fascinating about Amazon
is that so many of the stories
that I'm telling in this book
are about the leaders
that go first,
get all the arrows
in their back,
and then someone
comes to behind them.
First there were Six Degrees,
then there was Friendster,
then there was Myspace, and
then Facebook, blah, blah, blah.
The only major example that
I can think of any category
in the modern tech era where
the major leader that came out
first is still the undisputed
800 pound gorilla in its space.
And obviously Amazon
was not the first people
to do e-commerce online.
They weren't even the first
people to sell books online.
But the fact that they
were the first people
to popularize e-commerce
and that they're still
the ones that are
killing it today,
that's the thing
that's the most amazing
if you look at it from
a certain perspective.
And again, I mentioned
I went to the library
to look up old issues of
"Forbes" and "Fortune"
but also things like "Industry
Standard" and magazines
that haven't existed
for 20 years.
It was amazing to me how late
you would still get articles
about, are we ever going
to be able to convince
consumers to buy online?
Are we ever going to be able
to convince consumers to put
their credit cards online?
I'm talking about as
late as Christmas of '98.
Christmas of '99 was really kind
of thought of as this, well,
this is finally when Americans
have accepted e-commerce
in a major way.
Which we'll get to the
dot-com companies in a second.
But before I get there, I
want to spare a word for eBay,
because eBay was
another company.
We don't think of
eBay, again, god
bless them, as a major
player in tech today.
But think of three
major things that
eBay did where I can't
imagine the world if they
hadn't pioneered these things.
Number one, they taught
Americans to trust strangers.
And like I just said,
people were like,
are we ever going to convince
people to put their credit
cards online?
Are we ever going to convince
them that they can buy and sell
from a company?
Well, eBay convinced people
you could buy and sell
from somebody in South Dakota
that you would never meet,
never even know
their name, and you
could expect a reasonable
chance that you
could do a successful
transaction with them.
And because eBay had that--
anybody has a hobby.
Everyone has some sort of
hobby that eBay could serve.
So eBay, again, like AOL, was
a lot of normal people's entry
onto not just surfing web sites
but being active on the web.
So that's number one.
Number two, how were
they able to do this?
That five star rating system.
eBay invented the idea of
online reputation systems
that things like
Uber, Airbnb, Yelp,
all these sorts of things.
We live in the tyranny of
the five star rating now.
And there are good and
very bad things about that.
And it was never perfect
even when they created it.
But the fact that they created
the system that allowed people
to have a reasonable level
of trust of strangers,
that your reputation
followed you around,
that was one of the
reasons why eBay won
is because once you invested,
it's the network effect,
once you invest if
you're a buyer or seller
and have a good
reputation on eBay.
Amazon, Yahoo, tons
of people came at them
in the auction market.
But so many people
had invested so much
in building this reputation
on eBay that they weren't
going to go anywhere else.
And then the third
thing would be--
I'm blanking on it right now.
Reputation.
Oh.
And this is dead
obvious when I say it.
But again, put
yourself back in 1998.
They didn't own anything.
They didn't even take
possession of the goods.
So now when we think of any
platform business, especially
social media, all of the value
is in what the users are doing.
There's a story
that's in the book
that newspaper chains came
to kick the tires at eBay
at some point.
Which, for whatever anyone
says, the newspaper industry
was not stupid.
They could see that their
cash cow of classified ads
was at risk via the internet.
So all the chains came and
wanted to either partner
with eBay or buy them out.
And one of the
newspaper executives
takes Pierre and
Jeff Skoll aside
and he says, they really
want to do this deal,
but they know that
there's no way they
can sell it to the
C-suite because you
don't have any factories.
You don't have any trucks.
So the C-suite is going to
be like, what are we buying?
Despite the fact that our sales
are going up 1,000% a month
or whatever it was at the time.
So that's the third one.
This idea that you can
build a business that
has no tangible assets
other than your users
and whatever activity
they do on your platform.
So eBay deserves more credit
for being a pioneer that's
created our modern world.
I fought hard to
keep a lot of stuff
about the dot-com bubble in the
book, because not only is it
just friggin'
fascinating, but I think
coming from the
tech industry, it's
sort of like I say in the book.
My grandparents lived
through the Great Depression.
So any time anything
got too good,
they were always convinced
that a depression
was around the corner.
And I feel like in
tech, anytime all
of a sudden there's a big
IPO or VC investing goes up
by whatever, whatever,
everyone's like, there's
another bubble, there's another
bubble, there's another bubble.
I did a ton of research, and
I hope if you read the book.
The dot-com bubble, for a
lot of structural reasons,
is something that we're not
likely to ever see again.
It came at the end of the
longest bull market in history.
The baby boomers were in their
peak retirement savings years.
There was a ton of money
that had to go somewhere.
The journalist Maggie
Mahar says in the book,
if the dot-com companies
hadn't come along,
someone would have
had to invent them,
because Wall Street needed
to invest in something.
I mean, there's
always going to be
bubbles in any new industry or
new tech and things like that.
But this idea that
in '98, '99, CNBC
was on every TV and
everybody was invested.
Among the million
fantastic stories,
the idea that K-tel, who
marketed those top 40
hits or whatever.
It was a music
label, essentially
in late '98 or early '99.
All they did was
send out a press
release that said that they
were going to create a website.
And in 24 hours, the stock
went from like $4 to 32.
There's so many stories
like that in this book.
Pixelon was a company that
raised $20 million in VC
and blew all of it on their
launch party in Las Vegas.
They had The Who play.
They had the Dixie Chicks play.
It turned out that actually the
founder was a legit scammer.
He was under an alias.
The FBI eventually came and
arrested him, blah, blah, blah.
But as I also point
out in the book,
it was this weird time where--
I actually don't
have the page, so I'm
going to try to do this
somewhat from memory.
But in I think it
was January of '98,
if you invested $1,000 in
Amazon and $1,000 and Yahoo!
by the end of '98,
that $2,000 investment
would be worth
something like $78,000.
Now, these are not tiny stocks
that no one had ever heard of.
These are companies that are
on CNBC every day or whatever.
So there's this time
period where you can just
pick any company, and if you
get in at the right time,
you can 30x, 100x.
Some of the best--
the best investment
of the time was eBay.
If you invested in
eBay's IPO, I think
you did something like 10,000%.
And by the way, eBay
went down a little bit
after the bubble
burst, but it actually
continued to go up
after the bubble.
So if you want to go
back in a time machine
and do your best dot-com era
investment, it's eBay again.
The dot-com bubble
is funny in the sense
that it was obviously
the greater fools thing.
Everyone knew it was a bubble.
You're just trying to
ride it as far as you can
and hopefully get out before
the people behind you get out.
And towards the
end, you just had
to have a pulse and a business
plan written on a napkin.
Again, there's a story in
here about one of the VC firms
where they shared their
numbers and in '96, they
would get 400
business plans a year.
By '98, it's 2,000.
By 2000, it's something
like 15,000 business plans.
And there's a quote
in there from one
of the entrepreneurs that
says, yeah, you just showed up
and you just said you
were an internet company
and they would just
hand you money.
So there was a lot of garbage.
And that's the reason
why the bubble burst.
However, and I'm not the first
person to point this out,
how many of the ideas that were
crazy in the dot-com bubble
have come true today?
One of the most famous
ones was Webvan,
which is grocery delivery.
Go down the list from Instacart
to Amazon to whatever.
We all remember pets.com
because of the sock puppet.
But they were also famous for--
famously dog food
is a 40 pound bag.
They were doing free shipping.
Again, the statistics
are there in the book.
But they were essentially
losing not only money
on every order they shipped.
They were losing $2 for
every dollar they brought in.
But again, that's something
that has been fixed.
You can go buy dog
food online now,
and people have
figured this stuff out.
The logistics have
gotten better.
Myspace.com was a
company that IPO-ed.
It's not the Myspace
you're thinking of.
It was literally you would
put a widget on your desktop
and you could put
files in there.
It was cloud storage.
There's tons of examples of
this that it was just too soon.
The infrastructure wasn't there.
But they're good ideas.
And so that's one
of the reasons why
I think doing a book
like this is valuable.
Everybody in tech wants someone
to come up and tell them, well,
where are we going next?
What's next?
How much can you
learn by looking back
at the things that
were either dumb ideas
and are always going
to be dumb ideas
and learn that
lesson or that were
a dumb idea in a different time
but didn't work for reasons
that now would work?
And one of the things about
the dot-com bubble, that we'll
talk about Google
here in a second,
that the people that came after
the bubble took advantage of
was they laid this entire
infrastructure of fiber.
There was a bubble
that no one remembers
concurrent with
the dot-com bubble.
Things like Global Crossing
and Enron and all this stuff.
They laid all of this
fiber all around the world
so that when Google
comes along and there's
90% unused fiber
around the world,
Google is able to pick
it up on the cheap.
So the dot-com bubble
has to be remembered
as A, the lessons of the
ideas that were too soon
but maybe can work later.
But then also the
infrastructure that
created the circumstances
that allowed
the resurrection and
Web 2.0 that Google
was very much a part of.
We debated how much I
should talk about Google
at Google, because I don't
know how much you guys know
about Google.
There's actually the
better part of two chapters
about the Google story.
Cute stuff about
Larry and Sergey
meeting each other in
college, which you probably
have heard these stories.
And they didn't like
each other at first,
because they're both the
smartest guys in the room.
And so there was a little bit of
friction, like the frisson of,
well, I'm going to
one up this guy.
I'm going to one
up, one up, one up.
You probably know
some of that stuff.
The thing that I
liked to focus on
was, obviously, fixing search.
How would the web
and the internet
function had they not done that?
That's Google's
miracle number one.
Google's business
miracle number two
is obviously AdWords,
AdSense, creating
the greatest advertising
engine devised by man.
But y'all didn't invent that.
A company called goto.com did.
And GoTo was a bubble
era company, came out
of an incubator, and
it was a straight pay
for position search engine.
Actually got a lot of success.
It went on to power
the paid search
for Yahoo! and AOL and
others as Overture.
They changed the
name to Overture.
And again, I actually
used GoTo at the time
before AdWords came along.
But why did I switch to AdWords?
Because like Google
tends to do, even
if they don't think
of the idea first,
Googlers tend to think they
can always do it better.
And they did, because instead
of a straight pay for position,
when AdWords launches,
it has the quality scores
and things like that.
So as I point out
in the book, there's
almost no example of
this that I can think
of in even any other industry.
It was a win-win-win
for everybody,
because they did the
testing and the users
actually preferred the ads
because of the quality score.
They were useful.
You do the AB testing
and you put the ads there
and there's actually people are
happier and do more clicking.
Advertisers like
me at the time are
paying less, because if
my ad is more relevant,
it goes to the top, but I'm
still paying what I'm bidding.
And Google's happier
because, again,
even if someone's
willing to pay $1 a click
and I'm only willing to pay
a nickel a click but over 100
searches I get
clicked on 21 times
and that dollar bid only
gets clicked on once,
Google makes more money.
Win-win-win.
It's a miraculous market.
That's the second miracle
that I give Google credit for.
Another company or
story that I thought
I knew that then actually
doing it I realized what
the real story was was Napster.
So if you remember Napster,
you think music piracy, a bunch
of college kids that just--
broadband is
becoming ubiquitous.
And so this is the
first time that media
has to deal with
piracy in a major way.
I talked to a bunch
of the Napster guys.
And it's so funny.
And most of them to this
day still cling to this.
And if you read their
quotes, they were right.
They said at the time,
they say to this day,
we knew this was the
better distribution method.
That again, why do you
put something in a box,
shrink wrap it, and
put it on a shelf?
And they were talking
about things like Spotify,
like Netflix for a
slightly different model.
In 1999, Sean Parker is on
MTV talking about, well,
we think it'll be
a subscription,
you're going to
be able to get it
on your phone or your
computer or whatever
the device of the future is.
He has a quote.
They were right about that.
But what I realized that the
true story of Napster was is
we live now in a world of
unlimited selection and instant
gratification.
If I tell you about a song, a
movie, a book, a TV show, hey,
this is cool, you
should check it out,
you expect that in 10
seconds, you can try it out.
Unlimited selection,
instant gratification.
They were screaming
this in 1999, 2000.
This is what the consumer wants.
And actually, if you give it
to them, they'll pay for it.
And it's true.
What does Spotify have?
I think it's approaching 90
million paying subscribers now.
Netflix is approaching
200 or 250 million
paying subscribers worldwide.
The unlimited selection
part of that equation,
instant gratification is
probably what makes people pay.
But I don't think
that we appreciate
the unlimited
selection part of that.
I remember the first time
I came to New York in 1998.
The thing that I wanted
to do more than anything
was go to Tower
Records, because I
knew that they would have
CDs that I couldn't get back
in Florida.
And you can talk about
the good and the bad
of that, of the idea of
discovery and serendipity
is maybe lost when you
can get anything you
want as soon as you want it.
But I think that
Napster deserves
to be thought of not
just as a story of piracy
but as essentially laying
the template for media
in the digital age, even
though they didn't get there
because of Sean Parker's
unfortunate emails that
got brought up in
discovery in the trial.
Let's see.
For the purposes of time, what
else do I want to talk about?
The Web 2.0 era, to bring
Google back into this,
because again, I was there
and I was doing companies
at the time.
It's sort of like you have to
be in a zeitgeist to just know.
In 2004, 2005, you
could feel that there
was stuff happening again.
Google's IPO was a
big part of that.
I'll never forget people
just being like, when we all
found out that Google was making
the amount of money it was
making, it was like, holy S.
Because y'all really did
make the internet make money
at scale for the first time.
No one had.
This is at a time in 2003
when Amazon's a $5 stock
and people are thinking
they might go under.
Basically no one
in the Web 2.0 era
had proven that they
could make money.
Yahoo!
AOL, they all kind
of rode the bubble,
but they weren't
sustainable businesses.
So your guys's IPO in 2004
is a big part of that.
But then I remember Flickr
for the first time, Delicious,
and reading "Tech Crunch."
When "Tech Crunch"
first came out,
you would read it every
day not because they
were doing these journalistic
stories about the tech
industry, but because
Mike was just posting
new startups every single day.
And you would literally
email Mike and be like,
hey, Mike, I'm doing this, and
he would write a post about it.
It was just this
weirdly magical time
when you would read a blog post
and find out about something
like Flickr and then
dig a little deeper
and then find out about things
like taxonomy and tagging.
And it was this 1,000 flowers
blooming sort of period where,
which I want to point out, and
I said this last week on a radio
thing, why did that happen?
We kind of have to credit the
Microsoft antitrust trial.
Why was Google able to flourish?
Why did Amazon not
swoop in and buy--
why did Microsoft
not swoop in and buy
Amazon in 1998 or whatever?
Why were all these
companies like Google,
like Facebook, like name any.
Because there was not
this rapacious 800 pound
gorilla that is willing
to come in and cherry
pick all of the most
promising crop of startups.
I'm not here to
talk about things
like regulating tech and
antitrust and things like that.
But the '00s are an entire
decade where companies can come
up and there's not this
oligopoly at the top
that's going to sharecrop
everybody off and Borg-like
absorb them.
And there was this
whole flowering
of all of the companies
that we're now
very familiar with today.
So something to think about.
That if you have
a period of time
where you're allowing companies
to innovate and to find
their product market fit without
being absorbed by the Borg
right away, a lot of
good things can happen.
The Facebook chapter.
I essentially wanted to sort
of write the anti movie,
because everybody
knows the movie.
And while the movie
was not inaccurate,
there's obviously some
Sorkin-ing going on there
and changes made for
entertainment value.
I kind of focused
more on this idea
of this modern
startup, a startup
like we think of it today.
A kid in a dorm room
has a great idea.
Again, in the wake of
the bubble bursting,
I think it was the
Digg guys or something,
there's a quote in there
about how I think digg.com,
if you remember that,
they launched for $10,000.
And within six months,
they're getting more traffic
than "The New York Times."
It's because, again, the
infrastructure had been laid.
We now have things--
if you start a
startup now, there's
all these open source tools
you just pull off the shelf.
Google had the advantage
of after the bubble
burst, everybody's out of work.
So Google is the only game
in town for picking off
the best talent.
But in the Facebook story,
I more wanted to tell--
because it's fascinating, and
there's a lot of Sean Parker
quotes that illustrate
this, how much it was a lark
and for how long it was a lark.
Even after they go
out to California,
even after they don't
go back to Harvard,
Zuckerberg wanted
to do a thing called
Wirehog, which was like a
Napster 2.0 sort of thing.
And again, this is from
Sean Parker speaking,
so take this with
a grain of salt.
But he essentially has
to take Zuckerberg aside
and say, forget Napster.
I know that was the
coolest thing that
ever happened when you were 19,
but you've got something here.
This is the thing.
Facebook is the thing.
So I was fascinated
by how much--
and there's the famous stories
about showing up to VC meetings
in pajamas and I'm
the CEO, bitch.
How much it was kids playing
adult for how long it was.
Insert your thoughts
about what that
did to the culture
of the company here.
But I'm also fascinated
by, famously,
another Harvard
dropout was Bill Gates.
And Bill Gates is a
genius in a lot of ways.
But the argument that
I make in the book
is the interesting entrepreneurs
are the entrepreneurs that were
not born to be entrepreneurs.
But they stumble on
an idea that's genius
and then they make themselves
into the person that
can bring that idea to life.
I think that Bill Gates
was a person like that.
If you read
biographies of Gates,
he was an enfant terrible
of the tech industry.
Stories of strippers and
things like that back
in the early '80s
and things like that.
He evolved into a person
that could create the most
valuable company in the world.
The Facebook story is a lot
about Zuckerberg turning down
$1 billion from Yahoo!
Viacom wants to come in.
They want to turn it into MTV.
When Myspace gets
bought for $700 million,
everyone's like, wow, maybe
that's the price we should.
So what I was interested
in in the Facebook story
was that evolution of Zuckerberg
and the evolution of the idea
into believing that
this is a product.
What other product,
before Facebook,
was your potential addressable
market every human being
on the planet?
Maybe Coca Cola.
I think that realizing
that and then
being able to execute on that
is the thing that fascinates me
about the Facebook
and Zuckerberg story.
To wind up here, and
again to come back
to the notion of too
soon, I do tell the story
of the proto social companies.
Six Degrees was founded in 1997.
And it's essentially a social
network as we know it today.
Want to know one of the
reasons why it didn't work?
There weren't digital cameras.
There's a quote
in here about how
they're having board meetings.
And how can we convince people
to get photos and print them
out and then fax
them to us so that we
can have profile pictures?
When you think of an idea,
why does an idea not work?
Why is it too soon?
Because the technology wasn't
ubiquitous to have profile
pictures.
Friendster didn't work
because, famously, they
didn't engineer it well enough.
I had him on the podcast
and he'll straight
up admit that, yeah.
The ability to engineer
something at that scale,
again, people like
Google and Facebook
deserve credit for putting
that sort of stuff together.
And then why did
Facebook beat Myspace?
I go into that as well.
I go into forever I can
remember hearing that mobile is
going to be the next big thing.
You're going to get the
internet on your phone.
And I, like everyone
else, was like, well, why?
If I want to get
on the internet,
I'll sit down and do it.
So Palm and then
Newton and BlackBerry.
I tell those stories.
And I'm going to end with
this like I end with the book.
What I realized in writing
the conclusion of the book,
because I knew I wanted
to end with the iPhone
and with Steve making
that demo on stage.
And it's three things.
Are you getting it?
It's not this, this, this.
It's one device.
I think that the reason
that mobile didn't take off
for so many years when you could
have had a phone that would get
you the internet in
2000, 2002, for all
the various reasons, Wi-Fi,
4G, broadband wasn't built out.
All these different reasons.
The real reason is
because there wasn't
anything for normal
people to do with it.
The iPhone comes out in 2007.
Six months later, Facebook
opens registration to everybody.
When the app store
is launched in 2008,
one of the first 20
partner apps is Facebook.
So mobile didn't take
off because there
wasn't anything for normal
people to do with it.
And then all of
a sudden, there's
this one device that is
not only the perfect device
for consumption of social stuff.
It's the perfect tool for
creating social content.
So maybe you had to have
Facebook go mainstream
for the iPhone and
smartphones to go
mainstream and vise versa.
Because would my mom
care about Facebook
if she couldn't pick up her
phone and check it 30 times
a day?
And she couldn't take pictures
and share stuff herself.
So I think, getting to
this theme of too soon
or having the perfect
timing, I think
that the reason that the modern
world is mobile and social
today is because the
iPhone and Facebook opening
registration happened within
18 months of each other
and the two complemented
each other perfectly.
And that's the modern
world we now live in.
And I think I'm right on time.
So if anybody has
questions, I'd be
happy to take questions
for a few minutes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: Hi, and
thanks for coming.
Do you have any
examples of things
you discovered researching that
the world wasn't ready for yet
but that you think the world
now is ready for that we
don't have yet?
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: Isn't
it funny VR and AR?
This is not really going
to answer your question.
But I remember in the '90s
that VR was the next big thing.
And Jaron and everybody.
Some of the same
people were telling you
that that are telling
you that today.
Maybe I'm thinking
of this as my answer
because I was just talking
about the mobile stuff.
It's like, when are we going to
get what I just said is people
sometimes call it a killer app,
but for things like VR and AR.
We're not just it's the
VisiCalc for PCs or whatever.
But it's the thing that's
it's like, oh yeah, that's
why I would buy this device.
So in a way, I'm
answering your question
by saying, isn't that where
we are now for VR and AR?
Except it's just not happening.
And I'm not a skeptic
or a pessimist on this.
I'm actually genuinely,
at this point, confused.
But something that is
the right time for now?
All of the dot-com
companies, like I said,
have basically
borne fruit in 2.0.
You know what?
I don't have a good
answer for that one.
AUDIENCE: That's OK.
If there was great answer,
someone would probably
have done it already.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: No, no, no.
AUDIENCE: No, that's
not how that works?
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: No.
And when you think--
the famous story
about Google is who
needed another search engine?
There was Altavista, there
was Yahoo! there was Excite
or whatever.
That was the
dumbest startup idea
in the world except for one
little thing is that it worked.
So even if the
market is saturated,
even if everyone's like, well,
we've tried that 1,000 times
and it doesn't work.
But if yours does,
then it doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: Yeah.
You can line up too if you want.
AUDIENCE: So one thing
about the internet
was that until fairly recently,
the majority of the world
was still not using it.
And so you could come up
with this crazy new idea
and there was all
this room for growth.
But we're slowly
getting to the point
where we're hitting
that saturation.
The growth of the
internet is starting
to slow down in terms of
penetration worldwide.
Do you think that once
we get to the point
where most people who can afford
to have any kind of connection
have one that there's
still going to be room
to have these crazy new ideas?
Or will we end up in the sort
of mature internet market
where it's like
everything else again?
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: I
would argue you're
going to get better companies.
Because what you're describing
is the low hanging fruit
has already been eaten.
So all you had to do even five
or eight years ago was just
come up with a chat app that did
something slightly differently.
And then in 18 months,
you have a billion users.
OK, maybe that
market's saturated now.
So how are you going to build
the next great chat platform,
communications, whatever?
You've got to do it better.
As opposed to just you're the
first one in this virgin market
and just because you
planted your flag first,
you get to reap all the rewards.
So right, that is over, perhaps.
I mean, I would argue
that around the edges
because we're still
far away from 100%
penetration on a
lot of key details.
But even if we are,
then all that means
is you're going to
have to differentiate
by doing something truly
different as opposed to just
being the first one to show up.
So I would argue that from
a consumer side of it,
it's going to be
better, because you're
going to get more interesting
ideas and more interesting
companies.
Is it going to be
harder from a founder?
Is it going to be a harder slog?
Is it going to be
harder to differentiate?
Yeah.
But guess what?
Then do the work and
you'll reap the rewards.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious
if in your research
you found anything about how
changing notions of privacy
have affected the
course of the internet.
Because I was thinking about
how you mentioned getting over
this hurdle of I shouldn't
put my credit card information
on the internet.
And I certainly
remember, don't put
your real name on the internet.
Don't meet people who you
haven't met in real life
on the internet, which have
kind of all washed away.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: Or even
as late as 2006 or whatever,
articles of don't make
your Facebook private.
Don't put anything up.
No one will hire you.
Versus now today,
would you hire anyone
that didn't have a
social media presence?
They'd be like,
that's a little weird.
Go on, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well, so
that's the other thing.
Now it's almost like there's
a reversal of that trend
where, debatable to
what point, but kind
of the general internet user
is becoming more conscious
of privacy again.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: Yeah.
It's almost like we're
through the looking glass.
Again, when I'm in the library
looking at articles from
'99, 2000, DoubleClick would
do things that would make
the front page of "The New
York Times" that if I--
I can't remember the
details right now,
but if I describe it to you,
you'd be like, they did that
and it caused a privacy
uproar or whatever?
I'm actually
formulating a theory
about this, which is that
because the bubble happened
and people thought
that the internet was
a fad that was over, people
stopped paying attention.
And so when these companies
started to make money again
and they were doing things
that were data sucking
and things that annoy
us now today, it's
just no one was
paying attention.
And then when people start to
use their products, especially
the social products, it
just seemed fun and good
and whatever.
And so it was just this
period of about a decade
where no one was
paying attention
and all the products
on first glance
just seem to be net good.
So it's sort of like
the fox got away
with raiding the
henhouse for a while.
Yes, people are coming around to
paying attention to this stuff
again.
And so from people being super,
super almost too excessively
worried about privacy,
to not paying attention
at all, to now waking up to this
there's nothing you can hide
and I have no control
over any of my data.
I think we're through the
looking glass on that.
And to previous
questions, I think
that the way to
differentiate, especially
if we're entering
an era where there's
going to be greater regulations
and things like that, one way
to differentiate is really
going to be, you can trust us.
The famous don't be
evil motto was primarily
aimed at Microsoft.
Hey, don't go work
for Microsoft.
Work for us.
We're not like those idiots.
But it was also people
generally believe
in Google as a force for good
and organizing the world's
information and
things like that.
So I think that a startup
that could brand itself,
not just for branding purposes,
but as in a legitimate we care
about you first and our products
separate, second, and making
money third, I think
that you could stand out
in the current environment.
Because I don't see the backlash
ebbing away anytime soon.
I think that leaning
in that direction
is something that could be
pretty powerful right now.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious if you have
any thoughts on this
assistant thing,
where you think
it's going to go.
Is it going to change the
way we use the internet?
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: Yeah,
that's interesting.
I mentioned earlier, I do the
"Daily Techmeme" podcast also.
And I almost did a segment
last week about someone
wrote a piece about what are the
assistants doing right now that
are functionally better than
another input mechanism?
Aside from, hey,
Google, play this song.
Now, I know the argument can
be made, well, hey, Google,
buy this for me or hey.
But we're still at
this point where
functionally, for
a lot of things,
even if you get the latency
and things like that
and the ability to
recognize normal speech
and things like that, even
if you guys fix all that,
which you're working on,
there's still not anything--
yet again, it's the whole
idea of a killer app.
Where it's like, well, I will
speak this to an assistant
because it's functionally better
than sitting down at a keyboard
or using a mouse or tapping.
I haven't seen that yet.
And I have yet to be
convinced that there
is an entire class of computing
that in the long term--
because we've been
able to dictate speech
to text to our computers
for-- how many of you
actually when you write
emails do it over dictation?
You could.
You've been able to do
that for a decade now.
But you don't.
So I don't actually remember
what your question was.
But I'm still skeptical about--
convince me that
there is a class
of computing that that's
actually the better input
paradigm for.
I'm willing to be convinced.
AUDIENCE: This touches
a little bit on that
question about internet
saturation and just the fact
that there's a lot
of big companies
now compared to 10 years ago.
A lot of those markets seem like
they have really strong network
effects.
So how do you see things
potentially playing out there?
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: You know
that even five years ago, I
think right now today, even
after the recent stock market
stuff, eight of the
top 10 companies
in the world by market
cap are tech companies.
And each and every
one of them you
can point to certain
network effects in them.
Five years ago, even,
though there was only one.
It was either you
guys or Microsoft,
I can't remember, in the top 10.
One of the things
that concerns me
is that it is an oligopoly and
a consolidation at the top.
It gets back to
that Microsoft thing
about there was a
decade where there
was no one to come in and
scoop up the innovators.
But I also wonder
about that in the sense
that because there are so many--
there's not a network
effect for everything.
And there are certain
companies, the fangs among them,
that have these network
effects in certain markets
that are functionally
Buffett's moats.
And so this is not really
answering your question again.
But is it going to be
chipping away at those moats?
Because we know that
an innovator can
come around and eat someone's
lunch from below at any time.
But if you have these five or
six overlapping strong network
effect markets that
are essentially killed,
then is innovation going
to have to go around that
into other markets?
But then is the only playbook
that we know how to do
is to work with network effects
and build platforms and choke
off everybody else?
Here.
I've got an answer for you.
I don't think that the
current state of affairs
can last very long.
Not only because,
inevitably, there
will be innovators
coming up from below,
but I think you
guys, the big guys,
are going to start chipping away
at each other in various ways
that are going to weaken
some players and whatever.
And if you do get some sort of
a period of five to 10 years
of heavy battle on things like
assistants and smart speakers,
which everybody seems to
want to play in that field,
then just if everybody's
shooting guns
at each other "Reservoir Dog"
style, no one notices the guy
that's coming in the
room on the other side.
AUDIENCE: So here's a
related follow on question.
It seems like we've gone from
a world where things were
for a while very federated.
Like email was very
federated protocol.
Anybody can do that.
To a whole lot of silos.
You have more inboxes
now you used to.
Do you see that sort
of thing reversing?
Not just that someone
comes in and takes over one
of these things and becomes--
takes over a strong
networking effect area.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH:
What is Facebook?
You can already, for 25 years,
dial up your own web page.
You could share your photos.
You could do daily updates
and things like that.
All that any of
these guys have done
have just made it easier
to make a web page.
My mom didn't have
to know how to code.
I'm talking beyond things like
Weebly and things like that.
I'm talking about literally
all they did is make it simpler
to communicate digitally online.
So just go simpler beyond
that and beyond that.
I think that if you
extrapolate beyond,
you can go beyond the silos.
I can see a world--
Twitter should be thought
of as a web utility, not as
a company.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's the people
who have been lost in Twitter.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: Exactly.
So I can see that one
route of innovation
is to just continue to simplify.
And you can simplify
your way out of the silos
into what it would functionally
be sort of an open source
sort of environment where
messages can't be owned.
Think of it from that
sort of weird look at it
from another angle.
Why are messages in silos?
There's no functional reason.
It's text.
It's just text.
Because all your friends
are on this network,
so you're on that
network or whatever.
There used to be you
couldn't-- if you were on AIM,
you couldn't talk to someone on
MSN chat and things like that.
I think that, and I
hope this is true,
I think that the web tends
to bend towards open.
And we might 10
years from now look
back at this period as
an aberration, simply
because information
does want to be free.
And there's not
really any reason
why things like
texts or pictures
have to be siloed other
than those network effects.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRIAN MCCULLOUGH: I
think we should wrap up?
All right.
Thanks, everybody, for coming.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]